welcome to this video playing black
against SIPP for lark if you please they
keep forgetting winter bike at German I
am nice not playing it's a long time a
veteran of the ICC playing there for
ages let's check play this Karis defense
it's very similar to to the to the Bogle
but not quite the same 92 in this at
this point now I can play Knight f6 try
to transpose g3 is not so so common
hmm yeah I wonder if something to do
directly here like a queen bee 6 trying
to provoke III okay let's let's try that
III is not a move that white is probably
too enthusiastic about into the astok of
office the right one or about i don't
know let's say it's a movie doesn't like
to play let's see how there are there
are many possible ways to play this now
it cannot so i could also set up the
hedgehog but not sure if i should do
that I don't this is also possible team
a five in order to have a four try to
play against the night on d 2 which
clocks up yeah this is a good move
probably simply recognizing that this is
a problem peace maybe I can attack c4
quickly and even get be five in
yeah night's b1 intending 93 I think I
need to be quick here try to use this
loss of of tempo if he goes be three I
can really think about b5 that's a
possible means d5 is not bad yeah this I
didn't ready didn't really think about
interesting
ok let's try to develop yeah this is an
interesting point actually I could I can
also take with the night it's not
terrible at all I believe least let's do
that it's not so much that I that I
don't want the isolated pawn but the
idea here would be to play b5 and go for
the quick development but there should
be seven to come and have a long
diagonal so it's queen is also not not
ideally placed always yeah just take it
yeah I cannot just take it
keep gaining moves against the Queen and
now night before if he goes a three then
rook c8 seems like a yeah an obvious but
still probably good move Wow yeah I
didn't I didn't think about that at all
i just looked doing or do something
isn't it just just x-pro boost maybe he
wants to take this is of course possible
and then use the long diagonal may I
don't see how 95 I can also just take
sorry I don't understand the move
I really don't don't get it what the
ideas if he just takes on d 8 I mean
rope descendant didn't make much sense
yeah but I don't I don't see the big
point now yeah he can play that I mean
it's not completely completely terrible
but I can't take a bishop c6 rook c8
there should be some Roxy to our weight
this is two bishops are what they are
not doing here oh no I just miscounted
here I know I could have just played 94
with with a very distinct edge and I
just miscounted hi this is idiotic I
simply forgot that he's got two bishops
I know yellow kids it's still it's still
still a game fortunately
I take here is going to activate with
Roxy one but I need to I need any porn
that I can get now what's now before
yeah probably
what dick yeah i can i can show you
later i had very simple ways to to to
just keep keep an edge with no problems
and i forgot that just i just counted
this wrong name
okay well it's still it's still not not
clear at all white should be better but
it's not it's not completely clear cut
we should a five I can take be 5 i'm
intending to play be three maybe you can
play a move like OOP you want to
prepared okay at least now I get get
them on the second rank
yeah he still cannot take it so as long
as this is hanging so no Bishop d4 yes
yes I managed and he doesn't see
anything here check oh man did it yeah
this is x likely a game where both
players deserve any point white forfeits
on time yeah I think it's even a win now
yeah this was really a really bad game I
mean probably zero points for both would
be found we both played played really
really badly yeah Wow but the worst is
that are simply miscounted here I can I
can just take here I mean what this is
just just the easy solution just take
and now I mean Quincy 8 I didn't even
see this is in fact a move that wins
easily keeping the exchange but even
something like that just the Queen are
here it doesn't matter really he takes
Queen takes and this is a disaster
simply for white I have pressure against
before the pollicis is gone already and
the queen is got bad light squares this
is the easy thing that I saw and I
didn't see Quincy aight i mean this is
even better keeping keeping legs
but i simply i simply miscounted and our
queen c7 is still winning but I just
miscounted I thought I have an extra
next to exchange and I don't I simply
don't and yeah he it's just a very
tricky with the pawn won't be far
against the bishop the computer is
pretty optimistic at first for black now
be three is winning even yeah well I was
glad for two I found this trick enter of
this account to play and I think I
should be okay here I mean this is it
should be enough play as long as I have
for the combined power of the rooks on
the seventh-ranked he always needs to
protect their to pawn but it went it
really got to go terrible around here
yeah Bishop d4 just it's not exactly
difficult but he took here channel I'm
better again with the B point yeah just
just a disaster of a game yeah thanks
for watching anyway maybe you took some
thrill out of watching too I am playing
blunder of the blunder thanks for
watching